Another approach to virtualization is to modify the source code of
the guest operating system. If we can do that, not only can we avoid
problematic instructions, as I mentioned earlier
with full virtualization, but we can also
include optimizations. For instance. Letting the
guest operating system, see real hardware resources,
underneath the hypervisor, access to real
hardware resources and also being able to
employ tricks such as page coloring. Exploiting
the characteristics of the underlaying hardware. It
is important to note, however that so far as the applications are concerned,
nothing is changed about the operating system
because the interfaces that the applications see
is exactly the interfaces provided by. The operating
system, if there is an application that is running
on window, it sees the same API. If the
application is running on top of Linux, it sees
exactly the same API as it would if
this Linux operating system was running on native hardware.
In this sense, there's no change to the application's
themselves. But, the operating system has to be modified
in order to account for the fact that it is not running on bare metal, but
it is running as a guest of the hypervisor. And this is why this technology
is often referred to as. Para virtualization, meaning
it is not fully virtualized, but a part
of it is modified to account for being
a guest of the hypervisor. The Zen product
family uses this para virtualization approach. Now this
brings up an interesting question. I said that, in
order to do this paravisualization we have to modify
the operating system, but how big is this modification?